Fans in stormtrooper costumes, a hugely secretive
production, and major shade from the director of
"Gremlins." The truth about "The Mandalorian"
might shock even the most dedicated fans.
When the first episode of "The Mandalorian"
hit Disney+ in 2019, it came with a very big
reveal. As well as debuting a season-long
plotline that hadn't been mentioned in any
media or trailers that preceded the series,
"The Mandalorian" worked hard to ensure that
the existence of Baby Yoda would be kept secret
before the show's premiere. The first season,
of course, focuses on Din Djarin, a solitary
Mandalorian who must transport and protect
"The Child," a cute creature that was
quickly nicknamed "Baby Yoda" by fans.
Series creator Jon Favreau decided to
remain secretive about the project after
heeding the words of Donald Glover,
who played Lando Calrissian in "Solo:
A Star Wars Story." Favreau
explained to The Hollywood Reporter,
"[Glover] was saying that what people
really like now is to be surprised,
because it doesn't happen that much
[...] When Beyoncé did an album,
she would just put it online and everybody would
react to it. Just putting it out there spurred
a conversation that would become more viral and
bring more genuine attention than any marketing."
Disney executives agreed with the
approach, and kept all imagery of
Baby Yoda, who was eventually named
Grogu, out of marketing materials.
Before "The Mandalorian," Pedro Pascal was best
known for his role on "Game of Thrones." When
producers first approached him about playing
the lead role in "The Mandalorian," he was
apparently reluctant. In fact, Pascal's close
friend Oscar Isaac, who plays Poe Dameron in
the "Star Wars" sequel trilogy, was the
one who convinced him to take the role.
"You're welcome. I convinced him to do it."
The Jedi Ahsoka Tano, who previously appeared
in multiple animated "Star Wars" projects, first
appears in Season 2 of "The Mandalorian." For the
live-action version of the character, producers
hired Rosario Dawson following a successful
viewer campaign. She later told Vanity Fair,
"It first came from fans online.
Someone tweeted me and fan-castme.
I retweeted back and I was
like, 'Absolutely, yes please.'"
"Is he speaking? Do you understand him?"
Someone on the "Star Wars" publicity team saw the
exchange and sent the thread to producer
Dave Filoni, and the rest is history.
Some prestigious actors rounded out the
cast, with Academy Award nominee Nick
Nolte appearing in an unforgettable role. Carl
Weathers, noted for his performance as Apollo
Creed in "Rocky," portrays Greef Karga, while
former MMA star and American Gladiator Gina
Carano played Cara Dune in the show's first
two seasons. Critically acclaimed director
Werner Herzog stepped in as a pro-Empire crime
lord. Meanwhile, "Breaking Bad" and "Better Call
Saul" alum Giancarlo Esposito joined the
cast as ex-Imperial officer Moff Gideon.
The creative team behind "The Mandalorian" took
inspiration from many mid-20th-century works,
but they may have borrowed a
little too liberally from some
more recent pop culture entries. Joe Dante
directed both "Gremlins" and "Gremlins 2:
The New Batch," and he believes that Baby
Yoda owes a lot to Gizmo, the furry little
creature from his films. Speaking to
the San Francisco Chronicle, Dante said,
"I think the longevity of ['Gremlins']
is really key to this one character,
who is essentially like a baby [...] Which
brings me, of course, to the subject of
Baby Yoda, who is completely stolen and is just
out-and-out copied. Shamelessly, I would think."
And then there's "American Dad!" which has
been running since 2005. In the episode
"Persona Assistant," which first aired in February
2019, the alien character Roger develops a tumor,
which turns out to be a strange, sentient,
miniature version of himself. He names the
monster, which becomes a recurring
"American Dad!" character, Rogu.
"His name's Rogu."
"Ro-guuuuu."
While Baby Yoda appears in the first episode of
"The Mandalorian," the name Grogu wasn't
revealed until November 2020. Basically,
it's undeniable that both alien
babies have nearly identical names.
"Grogu?"
Season 1 of "The Mandalorian" wraps up with a
confrontation between the titular bounty hunter
and villain Moff Gideon. The Mandalorian
refused to return Grogu to his dangerous,
intended recipient, and had to
contend with a veritable army of
stormtroopers. A lot of anonymous foot
soldiers were required for the scene,
so many that the production couldn't come up
with enough authentic stormtrooper costumes.
According to ComicBook.com, the makers of "The
Mandalorian" took their problem to "Star Wars"
fans. Producers Dave Filoni and Jon Favreau called
upon the Chicago chapter of the 501st Legion,
a devoted "Star Wars" fan and cosplay club. Its
members appeared in the final two episodes of "The
Mandalorian" Season 1, dressed in their privately
owned, film-quality stormtrooper costumes which
they'd purchased, built, and maintained,
which is more than a little impressive.
"The Mandalorian" is the first live-action
"Star Wars" series and it was the first original
series to debut on Disney+ when the streamer
launched in 2019. According to Vanity Fair,
when "Star Wars" production company Lucasfilm
decided to pursue small-screen storytelling,
president Kathleen Kennedy commissioned input
from "Iron Man" director and known
"Star Wars" enthusiast Jon Favreau.
Favreau got to work after a
single meeting with Kennedy,
writing the first four episodes of a show
about a Mandalorian, a member of a race
of helmet-wearing bounty hunters. There
could have been an issue with overlap,
as Lucasfilm was also developing a movie about the
best-known pre-existing Mandalorian in the "Star
Wars" saga, Boba Fett. However, the problem
disappeared when director, James Mangold,
walked away from the Boba Fett movie to make the
fifth "Indiana Jones" film. However, Dave Filoni,
the creative force behind several animated
"Star Wars" projects, also wanted to make a
TV show about a Mandalorian. Kennedy put Favreau
and Filoni in a room, and they got along so well
creatively that they combined their ideas into a
single project, which became "The Mandalorian."
As it's set during the storyline
of the original "Star Wars" saga,
"The Mandalorian" is obviously inspired
by classic science fiction. Creators,
writers, and producers also pulled heavily
from other sources, including Westerns,
20th century world cinema, and Japanese manga.
Star Pedro Pascal told Entertainment Weekly,
"The Mandalorian is a mysterious, lone gunfighter
in the outer reaches of the galaxy. Some might
say he has questionable moral character,
in line with some of our best Westerns."
The main character's identity is shrouded in
secrecy, which is not unlike the Man with No
Name in Sergio Leone's "Dollars Trilogy"
starring Clint Eastwood. Series producer
and writer Dave Filoni also admitted to paying
homage to Japanese filmmaker Akira Kurosawa,
who influenced "Star Wars" creator George Lucas.
In an interview with /Film, Filoni explained,
"George's mentor is Akira Kurosawa. And so I've
done a lot of study of that [...] I have a really
small Akira Kurosawa figure and he is in every
episode I've directed somewhere in the set."
"The Mandalorian" also appears to crib from "Lone
Wolf and Cub," a long-running manga series adapted
into three films. Like Mando and Grogu's toiling
around the galaxy, "Lone Wolf and Cub" concerns
a ronin who roams the wilderness with a child he
protects when they run afoul of powerful forces.
The entire "Star Wars" universe
owes a huge debt to George Lucas,
but "The Mandalorian" has some specific
ties to the filmmaker. For one,
the show is heavily inspired by the first
"Star Wars" movie, which Lucas directed,
especially the episode's cantina scene. "The
Mandalorian" also uses technology originally
developed for the "Star Wars" prequels, with
20-plus years of technical advancements added in.
Giancarlo Esposito, who portrays Moff
Gideon on "The Mandalorian," revealed
that Lucas' input on the series goes
even deeper. Speaking to Collider,
Esposito discussed the creation of
the show's costumes and sets, saying,
"[Jon Favreau was] working with George
Lucas on this particular piece and making
it a piece that we can really relate
to now in our world that we’re in."
While Jon Favreau and his team used
practical effects as much as they could
to capture the hand-made charm of the
original "Star Wars," digital wizardry
was key to bringing the exotic world of "The
Mandalorian" to life. It's worth noting that
Favreau has a fair amount of experience
working on primarily digital movie sets,
as he's the person behind Disney's live-action
"The Lion King" and "The Jungle Book" remakes.
To create the jaw-dropping special effects seen
in "The Mandalorian," the filmmakers utilized
the impressive Volume technology, which
can turn any soundstage into a 360-degree
panorama. With the ability to render
detailed 3D environments in real time,
the team was able to create digital sets
that felt truly immersive. Discussing his
approach to using new technologies to
create the show, Favreau told Variety,
"Ultimately, it’s the human factor that
shapes our path into the future and it’s
the people who are innovating in
those areas, creating new tools,
that are going to determine what we
inherit and what the future holds."
At Star Wars Celebration 2019, Jon Favreau
repeatedly emphasized that "The Mandalorian" would
be one giant love letter to the original "Star
Wars" trilogy, and that tribute extends behind the
scenes as well. Favreau wants to make sure "The
Mandalorian" feels like our first visit to that
galaxy far, far away, and that means embracing
some old-school film production techniques.
Naturally, CGI and special effects are necessary
to deliver "The Mandalorian" on a TV budget,
but the crew is also using puppets, animatronics,
and special effects makeup whenever possible.
For example, Favreau really wanted
to make a model of the Razor Crest,
the Mandalorian's ship, to use during
production. Industrial Light & Magic's art
staff were apparently so excited about the idea
that they didn't just make a model. Unprompted,
they reportedly went home and built a camera
rig in their garages, recreating the hardware
that was used to make "Star Wars" back
in 1977. With a team that dedicated,
it's unsurprising that "The Mandalorian" became
an instant hit with viewers all over the world.